it's chapter 3 let's do this
I am experienced fear corn not all
working on behalf of general starter
himself you know how much misfortune you
are in if you do not release me no point
in keeping me here
it'll be very lenient to you and the
nurse and her family let me go
immediately you have my word on this no
I don't trust [ __ ] another and it's
splatter protection ok
I can I can I need a nice mask and in a
nice mask and a mask in here
an apple a saucer daily eating this
people like you do you like thank God
what's in here perfect just financially
it is people like you basement I just
say make them talk I need to make a
light box now we have a grandpa's got
some appliances aqua bar for this person
second [ __ ] off
let's stop [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I don't know
he's like tell my health I didn't
[ __ ] get out oh you love [ __ ] let me
tell you how this is gonna work I'm
gonna ask you one question you are going
to answer that question in a way I find
satisfactory and if you do not I will
saw your head off with this year
appliance you hear me so here comes
where are you people keeping the
captured resistance fighters I'm sure I
don't know what you're talking about is
[ __ ] there is no resistance
[Laughter]
[Music]
ah how my batch look if you want to know
the resistance fighters where are they
Helene's Ice and Fire Jason can never
make it
checkpoints everything looking for you
looking for you looking for you and then
us and soon they will in this place and
then you will be on your knees back in a
mess Calatrava rhetoric up over there is
this pistol Enoch walked by it was
garbage
the attacking Christina yeah yeah bingo
yeah well I think I'm a manager I really
just made he's a refugee Tuesday across
me uh yeah yeah this guys [ __ ]
handsome Americans bathrooms fibula
Misha the building we ask for your mercy
Lord as we make to turn it across I
don't know Pleasant if I got some are
specific up to eat
refuge
here's a puppy unit hey shadow [ __ ]
loss
holy [ __ ] take my hand never get him at
the checkpoint the road did not cite you
feel they not safe here I stay with car
we wait for you here kill everyone
now you got a sister Suneetha Tali twice
my friends we all right
any salmon
he has to be home spending maybe crazy a
piece that I guess [ __ ] it's a
mechanic's [ __ ] egg
yes Stefan fetch got stuck a ticket deck
launch eyes
[Music]
[ __ ] that it was des nein nein nein nein
nein para shouting ma yes step it back
here thank you
stop clever huh Top Chef [ __ ] a [ __ ]
topic
hey thanks
cello's that ammo here [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] I want to [ __ ] die
things are not looking too good for me
out here
I hope like recharge they get out
alright you broke their plane you're
broke you're fine
I don't know that right what the [ __ ]
down here
waste of time is what's down here happy
purse and that's for sure I'll be pissed
okay okay a lot of people are shooting
game one and I just I don't like how
things are going
[Music]
okay [ __ ] I gotta reload apparently I
could I could reattach that up
[ __ ] is that noise
I guess what go right away
shut up HSN oh my god I gotta beat this
out with everybody where the e section I
did that there we go back to the car
stop it oh [ __ ] oh that scared the [ __ ]
out of me
the name for an all-day such as that
[Music]
let me erase that [ __ ] nope nope a
daughter that mine may I'm just trying
to write the less you know I should use
the map tomorrow by that I get
[Music]
holy [ __ ] a lot of guys again it's a
[ __ ] hell
but I also need those ammo - out there
for me get in there get an AK match
I guess I should do some silent striking
you like that [ __ ] silent as they come
silent as they come don't look for he's
going I know that's people on here
[ __ ] a how do you lane out not enough
explain I'm saying I'm tinkle magnetic
[ __ ] it I need it [ __ ] [ __ ] it shut
I'm sorry Rock done if I sky stop okay
yeah
okay who else is here
[Music]
ahead there's quite a lot of people here
[ __ ] that's a gate
[ __ ] this closet down Wow
I don't know why that was so late hi
some [ __ ] Armor okay and the Sun we
are one
that's [ __ ] when I get going
Ali shut
I stopped sitting at me
Oh
mmm-hmm who else is around ah [ __ ] I'll
beat this then I'll be pissed
Buccaneers over
now get it a little pummeled here
okay so [ __ ] is that me
Oh Chet Chet
oh [ __ ] me [ __ ] me in the [ __ ] [ __ ]
fry [ __ ]
okay anyone else
so full saving your [ __ ] life [ __ ]
I know it out there
ain't no [ __ ] a hell is yelling listen
I hear you people [ __ ] out that my
door today the DA could just [ __ ] I
talk fruit no where'd that legs you know
don't have like gum all right did I got
clear the place huh yeah I guess not out
okay where's the car now jumper that one
I run for we're going away from this
what the [ __ ] is that
let's take out these [ __ ]
[ __ ] come on shut up get out of here yes
how do you take out this that said I
would [ __ ] it down
[ __ ] attacked
and one
I [ __ ] at that yeah maybe I should check
out the zero maybe that's a good idea
okay yes I'm sorry I've got a stall
stall
[Applause]
[Applause]
come on [ __ ] it up [ __ ] it up
well charge up car job charge up
come on [ __ ] [ __ ] oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
just leave me a lot
[Music]
okay yes I got it I'll pay for set up it
doesn't remain you miss us right
hello I just [ __ ] it fought off a
[ __ ] robot for you
oh my god yeah you and me Andre Berlin
why don't you put on some Nazi
paraphernalia sorry isn't like la cañada
shut up that's probably big make the
best coffee he didn't really understand
German
[Music]
yeah I guess
oh hello
hey guys rum punches 10 bags
avoid eye contact ah I guess I can't go
there listen to this my uncie church red
light hmm yeah yes Ruby yeah me get
phones in it Oh business that's the busy
[ __ ] my Germans not that good
all right I guess I'm out of file I deal
with that gut middle-class school mug
Fiona Inge is good my dentist might be
polite yes my love Lego handy twisted be
unimpressed was it in fact right Emma
desolation Island waters are passes
[ __ ] right away America disease and
midlife this kind of thing here the
mission done baby deer season
hundred SS baton well he's also serious
say say I'm addict decide ten hour and
forty the ears I thought yes I will have
a polite society can be taught not
before these events I don't provide
there but that's a bonus
okay me into the photo Larry Mendte
visible big mind
oh the I Jerez love eyes and yes the
internet photo that's an index consider
our students
Oh matter part and as I say my name is
Edith is a man on a disputed valid
there's a toccata you know yeah this is
good come on well games
she's my VND dusted the DMI Smith short
at what gazhams own this is the other
net survive as a VNC Iseman oh sure
and not disgusted by skulls away
Edison ass the [ __ ] study network in the
end earlier diseases in it did sort of
success that was a test the damage on
his reading of it destroyed that up he
did bitterly can please them photos
everything soul of anarchism can eat and
leash aria
the truth we'll all get killed do it
okay nothing gained Anna mhm
hey yeah I'm Vince extravagant animal
tigress rather angry
but nothing 40s today
there isn't any type of the other coil
is I'll try not that me any [ __ ] here I
could take though
goodbye building and I buy awesome show
huh
okay
by tagging ms de casa customs important
yes Lanier ah that's good yeah look at
that stick [ __ ]
oh thank you yeah okay we're going to
add this question here okay we're gonna
have a session here
Orion says cops a firstly yes
and
yes oh my god she's never been treated
so nicely I got my coffee yes
oh she is turned on by the strong
American avenge jail how comfortable put
my dick in your ass Tibet this only
pleaser one only [ __ ] you [ __ ] it she
[ __ ] her breakfast
holy [ __ ] oh my god my god - I mean
everybody lose about it
secret police headquarters on Tories are
in Union they bring presents i from
questioning the Turkish okay
we're done here that's her watchin y'all
thank you